Peace be upon you. I am Al-Hakimah Warda Al-Awawda. I
work in Al-Aqsa Hospital, the nursery department. Nursery care.
Fakfak. Al-Aqsa Hospital includes two departments, an
intermediate care department, an intermediate nursery and an intensive care department. Now, with regard to
women giving birth during the
Al-Aqsa flood war, we noticed a high admission rate in the
care department. There is no case in the Han Department, a pediatric care department.  We
are forced to receive children according to the intention of
children who were bombed, there are families, there is no mother or father, there is no one for
them, but we know who they are. We also deal with these
children, and also in terms of care, we always have a
family of one or more, which means the future of more cases
than the number of existing beds, except that it is in
Supply Transport.  There are certain medical supplies for
basic and necessary treatments. This is in danger. If
this treatment is lacking, there will be a problem. This means that this will have a direct impact
on the lives of premature patients, heart patients,
children, basic care. Sometimes there is no
soap. There is no paper in which we wash our hands. We make breastfeeding for premature and full-
term newborns. There is some sweet water to
boil.  We have a problem with births, as we do. I
mean, the care is almost always divided on our behalf.
Even if I tell you, there are more beds than necessary. We
worked one eighth of the cases on six incubators. Eight cases were on six
respiratory machines on six incubators on
our behalf. This child, Hassan Mishmish, came to us about a year
ago.  During the days they took him from under the rubble, from
the presence of his martyred mother and father, his mother and
father were martyred. They brought him from under the rubble. We made him a
full bath. It was all lead ashes, and God willing, even his
brother was also in the children’s section. Six people were sleeping with him. Is there anyone for
this baby so far who is free to hold him
from subscribe channel? Latest new from
alera